out of all the nominees tonight who
would you most like to get drunk with
good question
Carell probably I kind of adore Steve
Carell I just I just think he's a
wonderful man I'm very funny
well he's not nominated but with my
husband and trust me we just had twins
like nine weeks ago I'm Bridget Lee we
just smell wine we're gonna be like so
drunk it's ridiculous
miles teller no I just feel like I could
give him like good they're gonna be big
brother advice you know and then I just
feel like that would be you know I'm
giving back basically who's like the
most conservative of all the nominees do
you think Bradley doesn't drinks but but
I drink at him and I guess he doesn't
really drink but Bradley Cooper I think
he's a really smart guy he's a great
actor and Damien Chazelle Julianne Moore
she'd be fun she'd be alive but she foxy
and then a nanny - of course cuz they're
tequila so I like tequila so that works
out -
I'd love to see Meryl like slosh
dropping on the dance floor I would be
all about that